we've got one more hour to go in our
coverage here and we are pleased to be
joined by best-selling author radio
talk-show host Ben Shapiro whose most
recent book the People vs Barack Obama
the criminal case against the Obama
administration just coming out in
paperback this month we'll talk about
that book in just a minute but Ben
Shapiro what's on your mind what's up my
mind well I mean the presidential race
is always on my mind
avoiding covering the presidential race
as much as possible is on my mind
because if I have to watch Hillary
Clinton fake being a human for much
longer I'm not sure I can take it it she
does a a passable impression but she
inhabits what those in the animation
business like to call the uncanny valley
you know which is this if you ever watch
Polar Express you know that you know how
it's sort of it's just realistic enough
that it looks like human beings but not
realistic enough that you feel
comfortable you feel kind of disquieted
while you're watching Hillary Clinton is
there it's actually it's a term in
animation called the uncanny valley and
Hillary Clinton lives in the onion
actually as an address in the uncanny
valley and watching her try to imitate a
human is it's it's slightly odd you wait
for wait for the kind of glitch to go
off in her head to turn oddly and she
turns into data from Star Trek so I said
that's that's the fun and then on the
Republican side of the aisle as a
Republican is just watching them bash
each other so yeah that's how that's
always part of it but it's a beautiful
Sunday and and not thinking about the
presidential race for at least a few
minutes is a nice thing
well how unique are you here in Los
Angeles young Jewish conservative pretty
outspoken yeah well I mean in terms of
statistically the Jewish did use always
well left the Orthodox Jews about right
so if you find young Orthodox Jews young
north adopts Jews tend to vote like I do
not necessarily is outspoken or as
involved in secular culture all the time
as I am but it's a lie that means that I
would go with I'm certainly a
statistical anomaly if we had if we had
to calculate the odds of me being a
conservative young Jewish from Los
Angeles Harvard Law Education UCLA
undergrad I'm gonna go with 99% shot
that I'm a leftist before he got started
so this is the differentiating factor
right the yarmulke basically sets me to
the right well you recently wrote a
column on this issue why Jews vote
Democratic
yeah well basically ethnic Jews vote
Democrat but Jews who are observant vote
Republican and the idea is that if
Judaism is just how you were born then
it's sort of a meaningless statistic
people say a Jews vote acts well it's
like the same thing as saying people who
were born Catholic or born into a
Catholic family vote X well if you're
not a self-identified Catholic if you're
someone who doesn't practice but you
were born into a Catholic family
you're gonna skew left in all likelihood
well if you're a Jew and you were born
into a Jewish family but you have no
relationship with Judaism you go to
synagogue once a year you don't eat
kosher you don't keep Shabbat you don't
you don't do any of these things and you
call yourself a Jew mainly because you
like matzo ball soup and you don't want
to be called the white guy then you know
that at that point you're gonna vote
left and statistically speaking the
Jewish population is extraordinarily
secular or very highly educated lives in
major cities high-income you just
describe the typical white leftist
basically it's just that they happen to
be born with a name like Feinstein is
California a lost cause for Republicans
yeah I mean to be perfectly frank
there's what I like to say is the short
road and then there's a long road in
California back to back to power for for
conservatives the short road is that
people here suddenly wake up to the fact
that the state is bankrupt that the
crime rates are going up that we have no
water because we spent all of our money
on stupidity instead of infrastructure
then people start to get wise to the
fact that the businesses are moving out
of state and that the tax base is
leaving that's the short road the long
road is all of these things happen
nobody does anything about it the state
basically collapses in on itself and
then Republicans have to come back in
and clean it up sort of like what's
happening in Michigan right now so it's
gonna take a little while longer for
that to happen but it seems like it's
accelerating day on day here in in in
California and meanwhile the Republicans
seem like they just keep on it they keep
wanting to run as Democrats light which
is not going to be anything effective
here I mean if you want real Democrats
you vote for real Democrats in the state
of California I see the Republican Party
nationally sort of doing the same thing
the establishment Republican Party
basically there's two theories of how
you win elections there's the theory
that Ronald Reagan pursued which was I'm
gonna convince people that they're on my
side and then there's the theory that
Mitt Romney and John McCain pursued
which is I'm gonna convince people that
I'm on their side and one tends to be
successful and one tends not to be
successful and the one that Republicans
are pursuing is the one that tends not
to be successful try and convince people
yeah we know you're sort of on the left
but we actually
sort of agree with you most of the time
and so we're sort of in the same place
trying to carve off that middle voter
well we don't live in the era of the
middle of voter anymore not in the
United States but we live in the era of
a voter turnout as Barack Obama showed
me Mitt Romney won the independent vote
by pretty solid margin and lost by five
million votes it's really about getting
your base out finding that base and
having them turnout in enormous numbers
who do you like in 2016 at this point
well I mean it's it's it's hard for me
and I'll do the copy I don't know who I
like at this point I know who I don't
like at this point I don't like Jeb Bush
on the Republican side at this point I
think that Hillary is more formidable
than people are giving her credit for
you know mop her as robotic and she is
but it really isn't about Hillary it's
about what she represents to a lot of
people and what she represents to a
media that has decided in sycophantic
fashion that they want to smooch her and
they are they are dedicated to the idea
of another Clinton in the White House on
the Republican side of the aisle there's
a lot of candidates who are very good
and they all have their flaws so Ted
Cruz great on policy terrific debater
can come off as negative doesn't come
off in the same way as Marco Rubio so
that's his kind of downside you have
Rand Paul who is very strong in one
particular sector of the Republican
Party but is gonna have a hard time
breaking out of the libertarian sector
you have Mike Huckabee who's much more
blue-collar but also more big government
so he's gonna have a hard time reaching
out to the Tea Partiers and then you
have Marco Rubio who would be sort of
the the jack of all trades if it weren't
for his positions on immigration that
have been shifting wildly over the past
twelve months Scott Walker is sort of
riding above the fray at this point
which is why he's doing well in the
polls but he's untested on the national
stage so we'll see I mean a Scott Walker
can last great if not then Rick Perry
was formidable at this point in the race
in 2012 and of course that fell apart on
him do any of these guys ever come on
your radio programs uh yeah I mean Ted
Cruz has been on our radio program
before I believe Bobby Jindal has been
on the radio show before
Huckabee has been on the morning show
that I do before we've had a lot of
these guys and I've met a lot of these
folks and and I think a lot of them are
really are really good people not in fan
of all of them but but I think that a
lot of more good folks ben shapiro the
people versus barack obama
what's your criminal case against the
president so basically i in in the
criminal case against barack obama the
the the basic case that i make is that
we should change the RICO laws to allow
citizens of the united states to
actually bring racketeering charges
against the federal government
which would essentially shut down the
federal government which I know and
which I can deal with as far as the
specifics of the different cases that
are there multiple counts that I bring
against the Obama administration ranging
from invasion of privacy and violation
of your civil rights in violation the
Fourth Amendment and and federal law to
violation of the Internal Revenue
Service laws with regard to the
targeting of political conservative
groups everything from the the failure
to actually provide security at the
Embassy in Benghazi which really doesn't
mount involuntary manslaughter to the
the Fast and Furious scandal which is
also a case of involuntary manslaughter
there's a lot of criminal activity going
on inside this administration of course
the biggest problem is that the person
who is charged with policing criminal
scandals inside the Obama administration
is the guy who's covering up for the
Merrick holder who's certainly involved
in an enormous scale obstruction of
justice there's a reason that he's been
held in contempt by Congress and he'll
get away with it there will be no
consequences and this is what happens
when you have an executive that's out of
control and this goes back a long way I
mean as I say in the book this is not
just about Barack Obama i mean george w
bush was an executive out of control
bill clinton was an executive out of
control HW reagan this goes bad they
said there's a hundred-year history in
this country of the executive growing in
power by leaps and bounds president
obama has taken that and multiplied it
exponentially to the point where
basically the president thinks he can do
whatever he wants and and no one is
stopping him whether it's on iran policy
or whether it's on tax policy all of
that is very frightening to American
citizens or at least it should be which
is why I called for something as radical
as allowing American citizens to sue the
federal government for injunctions
against federal policy which would be
admittedly and something that would be
unthinkable
100 years ago the idea that the federal
government has things to do how could
you let ordinary citizens hold that up
in the courts well I'm not sure what
exactly our alternatives are when you
have the presidents of the United States
who can essentially do whatever he wants
even criminally speaking and given the
fact that no one's getting in Page
because since the Clinton impeachment
everyone has decided that's taboo there
are no ramifications for a president who
violates the law anymore
the numbers are up on the screen if you
want to participate in our conversation
with author ben shapiro this afternoon
2:02 is the area code seven for eight
eighty two hundred for those of you in
the East and Central time zones seven
four eight eight two zero one if you
live in the mountain or out here in the
Pacific time zone go ahead and dial in
we'll begin taking your call
in just a minute Ben Shapiro is a strong
executive in direct relationship to a
weak Congress yes I mean there is a
balance of power that's written into the
Constitution and the fact that the the
executive is seizing legislative power
would suggest that there is a a bit of a
zero-sum game that's happening here now
the Supreme Court has also delegated an
enormous amounts of power to the
executive branch and that means that
there really is no one to check them I
mean we the goal of the legislature
there's a reason article 1 of the
Constitution is not the presidency it's
the legislature we don't it takes until
article 2 for us to get to the powers of
the presidency which are pretty closely
circumscribed and the fact that that is
that has grown so much to the point
where the presidents of the United
States can unilaterally make immigration
policy the fact that the presidents of
the United States has talked about
unilaterally raising taxes he wants to
unilaterally put climate change
restrictions on the American people via
his executive branch agencies he wants
to pass through in Iran loosening of
sanctions regime that is he obviously
falls within the purview of treaty power
that should be approved by Congress the
president of the United States almost
has no boundaries at this point and it's
just a matter of how hard he seeks to
push so yes I mean and that's the fault
of Congress it's not just the presidents
I mean the president has to seize but
Congress has to give and the problem is
that we now have a system in the United
States I mean I wrote my my third year
Harvard Law piece is on this actually
the we have a system in the United
States where checks and balances have
been given away because the political
incentives do not match up in any real
way with actually holding power the
president gains power and and and
credibility with the American people the
more he exercises his power because he's
powerful he does stuff Congress gained
popularity by basically not doing
anything Congress gains popularity by
tossing everything over to the executive
branch because that way if something
goes wrong they can always say well as
the president recruited up wasn't me I
mean I just delegated this big I said to
the president go do good stuff if he did
bad stuff well that's his problem wasn't
me and so that means that they get
reelected the president of the United
States can can go out and be as active
as he wants to be Congress has an
incentive not to be particularly active
and the Supreme Court as Justice Roberts
has basically stated the Supreme Court's
incentive is to stay out of the middle
of that battle because the Supreme Court
doesn't want to be the people who are
constantly striking down active the act
to the president of
United States that that's probably why
Justice Roberts decided to rule the way
he did on Obamacare without any sort of
legal precedent to back him I mean it
was an egregious ruling and there's only
a political rationale for it Patriot Act
renewal June what do you think
well Patriot Act needs to clearly be
circumscribed at this point it should be
renewed but it should be it should not
be renewed in its current Langley
linguistic forum the fact is that the
Patriot Act allows significant latitude
to the executive branch or has been
taken that way and it needs to be
closely monitored and curtailed I mean
even the people who wrote the Patriot
Act at this point said when we wrote it
we didn't think the feds were gonna do
this well okay fine then you shouldn't
have written it that way but now that
you know now would be a good time for
you to go back and rewrite exactly what
you think the scope of the federal
government ought to be in monitoring
Americans communications because I
promise you that they don't need my
metadata to find terrorists we just
talked to the robert scheer head of
truth dig a little bit earlier today and
his newest book is called they know
everything about you and prior to
getting started here you said I agree
with him I know we've come full-circle I
mean there's a point at which the right
has met the left it's why Rand Paul is
seeing a significant uptick in his
popularity because in the case that he's
made that there ought to be you know
some privacy left from the federal
government I think Americans are
starting to take that a lot more
seriously and during the war on terror
before President Obama abruptly declared
an end to it without actual victory now
the George W Bush administration decided
that we were going to basically take an
enormous amount of data in order to
capture and catch terrorists that ended
up growing and growing and growing under
Bush and at the time we said okay fine
we'll trust you because the threat is so
great that we need to trust you and it
turns out that no matter how much you
think the federal government ought to be
trusted the it never ends well trusting
the federal government is very rarely a
good proposition and that's why you
really do need some pretty significant
limitations on what exactly the federal
government can and cannot do the update
people versus Barack Obama paperback and
the updates in that book I don't believe
so it's pretty much straight from the
from the heart it's cheaper there's the
update your previous book bullies who
are the bullies the bullies are in my
opinion the folks on the Left who are
trying to basically say that anybody who
disagrees with them is a bad human being
and this is the entire tactic of the
now president obama has used it to
tremendous effect the media uses it
ferment to tremendous effect the idea
that if you disagree on policy it's
because you're a bad human being
actually we saw this really effectively
jorge ramos did this last week marco
rubio
first of all i think it's fascinating
that hillary clinton is now a week and a
half into her campaign low over a week
in her campaign and she's been asked
zero substantive questions because she
just runs away from the cameras and we
get to talk about what her order was a
chipotle marco rubio meanwhile is
getting asked everything from substance
to nonsense but jorge ramos asked marco
rubio the question would you attend to
gay wedding that's a pure gotcha
question because there are only two
possible answers yes in which case he's
called the hypocrite cuz he's a
religious person going to a gay wedding
or no in which case he's mean ladies a
mean and nasty guy for not going to a
gay wedding and that's the way that the
left likes to play these things this is
why you hear a lot about the war on
women this is why you hear about how
america is a deeply racist sexist
homophobic place that requires the
federal government the idea is that if
we disagree on policy then i must
necessarily be a bad human being and
that's a bully tactic and it really is
nasty i mean we're seeing it play out in
the governmental sphere because the next
step of that is your main therefore I
get to bring the government gone into
the equation see how situations like you
have in Washington stay with Baron el
Stutzman Baron el Stutzman is the woman
who owns our liens flowers
Arlene's flowers a flower shop and this
gay couple comes into her she's been
serving them for 10 years and she they
come in they say we want to buy flowers
for our wedding Washington state now has
legalized gay marriage so would you
provide the flower she says you know I'm
a religious Christian I can't do that
here's a list of florists who will
provide you these flowers instead of
them just saying okay we respect you we
have different opinions we'll go across
the street to the southern flower shop
turns out folks that that some florists
are gay so they could probably find a
flower shop they would actually do what
they wanted to do they instead of doing
that they sued her and she was at that
her business was shut down she was
forced to pay a fine and this is what it
has now come to this is why when Indiana
and then when Indiana passes a Religious
Freedom Restoration Act designed to
protect the rights of religious people
to act in accordance with their religion
in the business place then Indiana is
called bigoted and terrible and horrible
what's amazing is that it's compared to
I mean it's they go so far as to compare
it to Jim Crow which is absolutely
nonsensical on every level
Jim Crow was a set of laws that forced
businesses not to associate with black
people ik weighting that with allowing
businesses to asset with whomever they
associate with whomever they want is
absolutely nonsensical on every level
the idea is that because Baron el
Stutzman is mean and nasty and cruel
that means that the government can do
whatever they want to her and she
absolutely has it coming the tyranny is
going to come from the folks who suggest
that the people on the other side are
necessarily by virtue of their belief
system they are necessarily bad human
beings it's not the belief system that's
bad the people themselves are evil and
horrible and nasty and terrible and
therefore they can be victimized by the
government and you're okay stealing
they're stealing their property or
putting a gun to their head and forcing
them to do what it is that you wanted to
watch them so how do you think Mike
Pence handled the Indiana system I
thought he handled awfully I thought
that was very poor I mean he should have
said this is a very simple answer but
this is what what's fascinating is that
Republicans conservatives have trapped
themselves and they've trapped
themselves over the last 50 years
because the truth is the truth is and
Rand Paul once came close to saying this
and then backed off of it he should have
stuck with it the truth is that in
America you should have the right to
refuse service to anybody that you want
and if you refuse service to somebody
who's black because you're a nasty bad
person and that does make you actually a
nasty bad person if you do that you will
lose money and your business will go out
of business
that's why they had to have Jim Crow
laws in the south that force people not
to do business with blacks because in
order to enforce a racist regime it
turns out that capitalism the only color
they care about is green what Mike Pence
should have said it's not even a
religious issue the fact that it was
turned into a religious issue is idiotic
I mean I'm a religious person but if I
weren't religious if I were an atheist
and I decided I was anti circumcision
it shouldn't be my responsibility to
serve a Brittany law right it's not my
job to serve a a circumcision ceremony
if I'm anti circumcision this is America
we still have freedoms now is it bigotry
for me to reject the Jew does that mean
that I'm anti Juno it just means I'm
anti circumcision you know we all have
to have the freedom to choose in this
country and it's amazing that the
freedom to refuse a consensual
engagement is now considered an active
of tyranny when the real tyranny is
bringing the government and in forcing
me to involve myself in what amounts to
involuntary servitude if I'm
involuntarily serving you by definition
that is involuntary servitude
Pence didn't say that he wasn't willing
to go basic on the principle and so
instead he ended up in this awkward
situation where he was explaining the
difference and it's true he was
explaining the difference between not
serving a same-sex wedding and not
serving a gay person there is a
difference I mean I can serve a gay
person all day long and not sort of a
same-sex wedding if I serve a same-sex
wedding presumably I'm serving a gay
person but they are not equivalent in
any way I mean I can I
conserve gay people all day long and not
serve that Kay wedding again I can serve
Jews all day long and not some abrete
mila the serving activity is not the
same thing as serving the person but so
he ends up in that kind of mushy space
trying to explain that as opposed to the
very simple principle in America it used
to be you could put a sign on your
business it said no shoes no shirt no
service now the question is when does
that become discrimination if I have a
religious belief that I'm not allowed to
wear shoes you have to serve me in your
business if I'm not wearing shoes I keep
kosher I'm looking forward to the day
when I get to walk into Burger King and
demand my kosher burger and they're
bigots if they don't serve me then
Shapiro is our guest with a lot of
issues on the table a lot of calls on
hold let's begin with mark in Twin Falls
Idaho mark you're on with Ben Shapiro he
reviews a coal mine precisely right down
to the last one regarding the Israeli
city think the affect on the Jewish vote
will be with Obama's boycott Netanyahu
before Congress well you will see an
impact it's not going to be as great as
people think it is because as I said
earlier in the program the fact is the
vast majority of Jews don't actually
care about Judaism or Israel which is
unfortunate now you did see a drop from
from the the Barack Obama levels of
support in 2008 to the Barack Obama
levels of support in 2012 he dropped
from about 78% to the Jewish vote to
about 65% of the Jewish vote you will
see a concomitant trap if Hillary
Clinton is the nominee and doesn't
separate off from Barack Obama's policy
you will see a continued drop but the
Jews will never vote in majority for
Republicans because most Jews again have
nothing to do with Judaism so
unfortunately it looked believing Jews
are the ones who are going to vote
Republican because they actually care
about Israel Jews who care about Israel
vote Republican juic don't vote Democrat
Joe's in Washington DC go ahead Joe then
you describe Hillary Clinton as a
inhuman robot and President Obama as a
perpetrator of involuntary manslaughter
and then you critique the left for
personal attacks as a fellow HLS alumni
I think you need to slow down
thinking about what you're actually
saying rather than talking so fast find
the essential loss analyses of what
you're doing for example if I say you're
a vain shallow callow narcissistic
coalescence disruptor and that's my
political opinion I suppose that is
using the pen Shapiro technique so I
wish you the best of luck with your mind
as you grow up well first of all it's
good to speak to my professors from
Harvard Law School it's good to hear
from you again
and and I appreciate all of the
compliments the fact that folks on the
Left disagree with me is a badge of
honor for me as far as the the insults
if I can't joke about Hillary Clinton
being robotic I'm not sure what I can't
joke about I mean seriously can we can
we all just lighten up a little bit
turns out Bill's election Hillary's a
robot let's all get over it move on ben
shapiro why did you call that or compare
that caller to your professors at
harvard law professors at heart the
truth is and harvard law i got along
pretty well with most of my professors
there are there a couple of people at
harvard law who who are known for not
being particularly tolerant of other
political viewpoints one is currently a
senator from massachusetts but there
were some there's a lot of harvard law
professor so i got along famously with i
was actually i got along very well with
Lani Guinier who was so radical that
Bill Clinton had to pull her nomination
when he nominated her for I think was
housing and urban development back in
the early 90s machee and I got along
really well look as long as folks have
an open mind it's fun to have a talk
with them that what I object to is well
my Elizabeth Warren story is that
actually when Elizabeth Warren when I
first met Elizabeth Warren my only dealt
with her a little bit she and I met at
the top of the W Hotel in LA because she
was recruiting me for Harvard Law School
at the time and in our first
conversation our initial conversation I
walked through and she'd read my profile
and she started grilling me I just
written a book about leftist bias on
college campuses and she suggested there
was no such thing as leftist bias on
college campus which is only which is
only discounted by every single poll
ever done on a college campus and then
she started ripping into Rush Limbaugh
at which point I asked her if she'd ever
listened to Rush Limbaugh and and it got
relatively heated which was an
interesting way to recruit but-but-but
Elizabeth Warren is she's a lot of fun
they think look I'm always willing to
have conversations and debates with
people it's it's
I get through my day so you know when
people call in and disagree that's
that's what makes it spicy have you ever
been told before that you talk fast all
the time I can't stop it it's and it's
it's it's unfortunate I've been really
working on it for a long time but again
okay so I will fall into the the Jewish
stereotype I'm a Jew
Jews talk fast and to my my parents talk
extremely quickly so everybody in my
family we sit around the table and it
sounds like it sounds like everybody's
on fast-forward all the time eventually
we actually hit chipmunk speed and then
we go silent and we go back in time one
time we ended up back in 1955 and I had
to I had to make sure that my parents
met and that I was born eventually it
was wild viki's in st. Augustine Florida
Vicki you're on c-span spoke TV again
I've read several of your works I've
heard you speak it David Horowitz of
goof out in Los Angeles one time at any
rate I'm calling for two things one I'm
a former Republican I am so fed up with
the party and the politics I wanted to
ask you are we still able to grab the
feet out of the jaws of victory this
time around are we going to foul it up
again and then secondly I wanted to say
we do need to recommend Friedman's book
freedom to choose that's a great book
about freedom of choice and also I want
to mention talking about civil rights
that Barry Goldwater refused to sign the
civil rights legislation because he felt
it deprived people of their freedom to
associate with those with whom they
wanted to associate which kind of
reflects back on this gay marriage thing
at any weight are we Republicans going
to lose Vicky Vicky before we get an
answer from ben shapiro when you say
you're afraid the republicans are going
to screw it up again in 2016 can you
give an example of what you mean yes i
unfortunately as a former republican i
broke my back for john mccain going
door-to-door down here in florida and
then also for mitt romney and i just
there were such lovely gentlemen but
they ran campaigns they just could not
communicate with the american people on
the level that they need
- and I'm afraid this will happen again
because we have such lovely people
running or who look like they're going
to be running on the Republican ticket
we just can't be as sharp as the
Democrats it seems and I'm not sure why
what's the solution
Ben Shapiro I think the solution is
getting down to actual basic actual
basic moral arguments the left when I
talk about how the left bullies and when
they say you're a bad person if you
disagree with them that's because the
left deep down in their heart they
believe that they are morally superior
and I believe that that's an unbaked
moral superiority it's unfounded - nor
unearned moral superiority but the truth
is that any any religious perspective
you take any political perspective you
take in essence at your very root you're
probably going to feel like you have a
certain level of moral superiority for
holding those beliefs I believe
conservatism to be a morally superior
belief system to leftism and if people
on the right aren't able to articulate
that then that's going to continue to be
a serious problem for them as far as the
Republican Party and why are they
actually going to be able to do any
damage here I think that the fact is
that the Republican Senate has been has
been less than useful thus far what they
just did in passing a bill that
basically allows President Obama to
loosen sanctions on Iran is truly
egregious it was played by the press as
though it was rebuked to President Obama
far from it that that bill basically
allows President Obama to loosen
sanctions on Iran unless Republicans can
come up with 67 votes in the Senate to
stop him that's going to be a very
uphill battle as far as the Republican
nominees I think there are some who have
started to learn about speaking moral
language speaking about the language of
Rights speaking in very basic and
meaningful terms that people actually
resonate to but unless they can speak in
those moral terms on a routine basis
then if they're gonna if they're gonna
do what MIT Romney did and try it out 57
point tax plans and talk about
everybody's effective marginal tax rate
okay I happen to know my effective
marginal tax rate because I just had to
I just had to sign a big check to the
IRS because of it but most people
actually don't know their effective
marginal tax rate so if that's your
pitch for President of the United States
which by the way was Romney's pitch that
if your effective marginal tax rate for
the highest tax bracket is thirty five
seven as opposed to thirty four - you're
gonna [ __ ] the economy I'm sorry
that's not very much of a pitch for you
to be President of the United States
next book what is it
well actually I'm working on a novel
right now which it should be kind of fun
I just felt like changing it up a little
bit so I'm working on kind of a
as most conservatives are at this point
a post-apocalyptic American novel I mean
I think most Americans are thinking
along those lines
as we buy our our canned food and
shotguns shells so I'm writing something
along those lines and it's it's a lot of
fun to write and then I've been thinking
along the lines of a couple of different
topics that I think would be interesting
to write about and one would be the the
kind of creeping tyranny of the American
mind this move toward I disagree with
you therefore I get to use the
government to do whatever it is that I
want to do and that's that's truly
frightening to me because there are
plenty of things that I disagree with I
mean as you can tell there are plenty of
things that I find is tasteful and
problematic and disagreeable there are
people who do things every day that I
find gross and terrible but I don't
think that that gives me the ability or
the right to use the government as a
cramdown mechanism on them forcing them
to do what I want I think that unless
Americans return to that vision of
government that government is really
only there to prevent externalities of
interpersonal actions it's there to
protect third parties then we're going
to get ourselves into a lot of trouble
now I know that's a pretty libertarian
perspective but I think that we're
becoming such a country of divided
lifestyles that it's gonna be difficult
for for us to even remain one country in
the long run unless we come to an
agreement that government is gonna have
to stay out of it we're gonna have to
just deal with each other on an
interpersonal level and let social
movements deal with the rest if you want
to live in a religious community live in
a religious community but it's nobody
else's business what kind of community
you live in and same thing if you live
in an atheist community for the nagae
community if you live in a Christian
community you shouldn't you should be
basically allowed to be left alone and
we all have the freedom of movement
we're all allowed to choose where we
live and under what lifestyle we wish to
live and the fact that we've decided on
a national level and it's happened both
right and left unfortunately that the
federal government can be it's the one
ring that you can use that power and you
can wield that power nobody can wield
that power properly I mean this is this
is why the marriage debate is so
fascinating because and when it comes to
same-sex marriage what the right has to
acknowledge is that the government tried
to for a traditional marriage and failed
in the government's attempts to for
traditional marriage were a complete
failure which is why I've for years I've
been advocating that the government just
get completely out of the business of
marriage because it's not like the
government did any good for traditional
marriage in the first place get the
government completely out of it let
people actually have interpersonal
contractual relationships with one
another's what I have with my wife I
mean we have a Jewett we have a Kotova
right we have a ketubah which is a which
is a Jewish marital document could tuba
ask a tuba we have a Jewish marital
document and
we also have our state marital document
I don't care about our state marital
document it makes no difference to me
it's just something I didn't register
with the government the kitumba's
hanging on the wall in our house as it
is in most Jewish households that was
the way that the Jews registered
marriage 2,000 years ago 3,000 years ago
and there's nothing wrong with it today
the idea that I get to make an agreement
with this one person how we are going to
live our lives that seems to me a better
system than having the government decide
what's an appropriate relationship and
what is not an appropriate relationship
in a consensual situation that doesn't
affect others Jim is in Caliente
California Jim you're on book TV with
Ben Shapiro Jim are you with us tell you
what Jim is gone all right we let's move
on to Taylor in Dover Delaware Taylor
please go ahead with your question
comment yes I have a couple of questions
for him one is on a personal level I
just wanted to know if he's ever served
in the military or anyone in his family
has ever served in the military I would
also like to know if he's so that held
that basically on destroying the federal
government what government would he
think that we would need to have in
order for us to stay at United States of
America and the other question is I
don't understand the Republican Party
right now because a lot of their
policies are coming from the and
in Stan man Institute which is based on
objective ISM and which is basically you
know the most non religious non or you
know she was an atheist to begin with
and it's like the Republican Party just
worships her especially Paul Ryan who
gives her a book to everyone and that's
all right we got we got that tell you
what Taylor why did you ask the first
question about the military because I
get sick and tired of all these people
that aren't military my dad was was shot
down or not shot down but survived two
plane crashes in World War two my
husband was in Vietnam
and Agent Orange exposure and he died
very prematurely because of that and all
the and I work for the United States
government for 30 years and all these
people that have never served their
government have never served in military
they always gung-ho military and they do
not you know they they it's like they
have never served in the military and
like right now we need to drill right
we've got the point I appreciate that
and the draft will add that to the to
the list ben shapiro okay so a couple of
things first of all I loved your
rendition of shake it off second of all
as far as your as far as your questions
about military service
thank you for your for your family's
military service obviously as well as
your husband's military service you
asked me why want to destroy the federal
government then you also asked me why I
want to bulk up the military those two
are in complete opposition so obviously
I don't want to destroy the federal
government
I want to restrict the federal
government to the tasks for which it was
originally designed including national
security and military defense as far as
the the argument the chickenhawk
argument which is essentially what that
argument is that I didn't serve in the
military therefore I can't be a hawk
number one I am not a member of the
police force I still get to vote on
police policy second of all when it
comes to who defines military policy hey
folks on the Left I will make you a deal
right now I will never speak again about
military policy if we all agree that the
members of the military get to vote on
military policy you happy with that you
think that's gonna go well for you I
have a feeling that's going to go very
poorly for you cuz it turns out that the
members of the military vote
disproportionately Republican and agree
with me on national defense and national
security as far as the the Iran question
objectivism the the what Republicans
like about objectivism is that it points
out the evils of collectivism that's
really what they like about objectivism
as far as Iran's personal philosophy the
atheistic notion that selfishness is the
ultimate value I think the most
Republicans actually don't agree with
that I think they like her description
of capitalism in some ways I think they
love her description of collectivism but
if you ask most Republicans do they
believe in thoroughgoing objectivism the
answer is absolutely not the vast
majority of Republicans do not believe
in thoroughgoing objectivism which is
why the vast majority of Republicans are
actually religious Jocelyn is right here
in Los Angeles please go ahead Jocelyn
yes I would like to ask Bishop hero wise
he's so focused
on the Obama administration with regards
to privacy and the lack thereof when
this issue was really accelerated with
bush in the cheney administration and
now that President Obama is in office it
is a big deal
[ __ ] his title read the People vs
Bush and Cheney okay as far as the
privacy question I actually called for
prosecution in in the book of people who
are involved in the in these
surveillance programs under Bush and
Cheney so actually you sort of make my
case the fact is that I don't restrict
it to Barack Obama when rights are
violated rights are violated the fact is
that the Obama administration did
dramatically upscale the amounts of
surveillance which is kind of
fascinating in light of the fact that
the Obama administration has declared
the war on terror basically in wine town
mode it's supposed to be ending so why
exactly are we ratcheting up the amount
of information about Americans that we
are currently gathering that seems to be
internally contradictory at least Bush
and Cheney were trying to give us an
excuse they were saying that we had a
war on terror and we were trying to
ferret out the folks who were dangerous
the Obama administration refuses to even
acknowledge that folks are dangerous I
mean we're in the middle of signing a
nuclear deal with Iran even as the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard today said
that they will not allow any inspections
of nuclear facilities so when you say
there's no threat and yet the threat
that doesn't exist is so grave that they
have to check all of our emails I start
to get a little bit suspicious
editor-at-large for Breitbart senior
fellow at the David Horowitz Freedom
Center co-host kr la 870 Los Angeles's
the morning answer best-selling author
of several books including his two most
recent bullies and the People vs Barack
Obama we've got about 15 minutes left
with our guests Ben Shapiro and Carrie
Yakima Washington good afternoon hi how
are you I'm Colleen I'm Aiman or I'm a
count out and I wanted to talk to mr.
Shapiro about the droughts in California
and I wanted to give him my suggestion
that we and watching to the States I
transferred up here after I graduated
from college in California and I fell in
love with snow skiing stayed they have
lots of water up here we have mountains
falling on people
and I want to and we have I am also a
child of an I'm an Army Corps of
engineer family kid okay I grew up in
Australia all over the world but for the
Army Corps of Engineers doing dams and
aqueducts third world project you know
third world countries helping people get
their their countries going anyway and
so I know how construction works and I
was born when the auricle dam was built
my dad is one of the Super's on it and
the California carry we're where are you
going with us I want to know why we are
not doing something with regards to
there is a chain of dams and reservoirs
and everything coming all the way down
all right I apologize I'm gonna stop you
there let's talk about the politics of
water yeah I mean the drought is a
really interesting situation because
when it comes to the drought it's pretty
clear that environmentalism in the state
of California has largely crippled any
efforts to to build new dams new
reservoirs desalination we have a giant
body of water it's just full of salt
it's right off our coast and it's really
pretty
uh Israel has somehow figured out how to
make desalination plants they're
expensive but since we're spending a
hundred billion dollars on a fantasy
choo-choo train that doesn't exist then
we might as well spend some money trying
to figure out how exactly to provide
water to people as far as building
reservoirs and and aqueducts actually
down from Washington State and Oregon of
course we should have been doing this
Pat Brown Jerry Brown's father actually
did a lot of these things Jerry Brown
just reversed all of that Jerry Brown
hasn't done anything on this for 40
years and now all the sudden he's
decided that he has to restrict
everybody's shower lengths well it turns
out that 80 percent of all water use in
the state of California is going to
agriculture and agriculture for all the
talk about how it's that what we we
create all the fruits and nuts in in the
United States in terms of actual fruits
and nuts the the the fact is that the
that that actually accounts for about 2%
of the GDP of the state of California so
in other words 2% of the GDP of the
state of California is actually taking
up 80% of the water now Jerry Brown's
plan is to reduce water usage in the
state of California by 25% in urban
areas to do that if he does that then
he's going to achieve approximately six
700 billion gallons of water saving
every year we need about 11 trillion
gallons in order to fill up what we've
lost but here's the reality 160 billions
of fresh water are being pumped out into
the San Francisco Bay every single year
to save the delta smelt another 250
gallons of usable water are being pumped
out of there to help the to help the
salmon swim to their spawning places so
we really want to hook them up and so we
have to make sure that they have active
sex lives by parently pumping useable
water out into San Francisco Bay you
know this is not exactly the best use of
water and and we're going to have to get
over the whole subsidies to industries
that we like look I like a lot of the
farmers in the Central Valley I think
that they're doing something that's
incredibly worthwhile however one almond
takes four gallons of water and and the
fact is that if you have one segment of
the population that represents 2% of the
GDP and 80% of the water use you know I
may think that almonds are more valuable
than my lawn I may think that's more of
a value to the United States than me
having along but guess what it's a free
country if I'm willing to pay for the
water I should be able to pay for the
water
the real reason all this is happening
really is because the state of
California has artificially kept water
prices low which means that it's
subsidized water used for a lot of
people in both urban and agricultural
areas and finiman allowed to go to
market price then you would have
actually had competition for the water
and then water usage would have gone
down I mean it's amazing you go to the
store has anyone ever run out of all
bottled water at the store has it ever
happened no because the market governs
when it comes to bottled water nobody
ever runs out of coke if there's a real
demand for coke they produce more and
the coke comes in the next shipment when
it comes to water because it's been
artificially deflated by the federal
government and by the state and local
government that means that that the
water has been running out for a long
time because of how we've decided to
divvy it up basically what's the
argument against desalinization the intr
in terms of the environmental argument
because you have to use particular
enzymes apparent there's biological
desalination and chemicals that are used
in order to make sure that that happens
and they say that a lot of the chemicals
are supposedly dangerous although Israel
has never had a problem with this and it
is very expensive I mean desalination as
a project is extraordinarily expensive
they should be they should have been
pursuing it 20 years ago they should
certainly be pursuing it now and there's
a new new plant opening isn't there I
think San Diego yeah they need a they
need to really ratchet up the water
production first or Tara's in Charleston
West Virginia
Tara this is book TV on c-span 2 author
ben shapiro
hello hello Ben it's great to talk to
you the the question that I have is is
it possible for states attorneys general
to possibly bring prosecution charges
against the Obama administration against
the members of Congress who you know
some there knows that the citizens and
the Constitution by sitting back and
turning their heads away while we are
flooded by illegal aliens and I'm not
afraid to use that term because that's
what it is illegal aliens and I just I'm
scared because what I see happening is
with giving the back taxes for the past
three years for these people you know
the free college education the housing
and everything to me that is buying
votes for the next election and what is
it going to take to finally have others
in Congress besides ted cruz and trey
gowdy and mike lee the great Patriots
that they are what is it going to take
to get these people to stand up to this
administration and tell them to pretty
much quit something their finger at the
American people thank you Tara well
people are gonna have to get primary as
far as my own stance on illegal
immigration my feeling about immigration
is very obvious if there's no welfare
state I don't care who comes I'm totally
open borders if there's no welfare state
because if people aren't coming for free
stuff great come in come in and work
seriously that's totally fine in fact if
you want to come here and you want to
work I will trade you I would if I were
king right which I which is a principles
which I'm fundamentally opposed but if I
were king for a day I would trade I
would trade the illegal immigrant who
wants to work for the guy who was born
here and who's been sitting on welfare
his entire life because it's your
character that matters not your place of
origin the problem is of course that we
have this entire system of benefits that
we're now giving out to people and so
that draws people here they're not bad
people I mean everybody is is inherently
it has selfishness to them we're all
were all self-centered we're all taking
benefits from the federal government at
some level I took Pell grants everybody
takes something from the federal
government until we change that
mentality
until we stop offering a lot of these
things in the first place then it's
going to be a lost leader as far as what
can States Attorney General's I mean the
answer is you're watching it happened
right now the state of Texas is suing
the federal government over President
Obama's amnesty program it's been
temporarily put on
hold by an injunction will see if it if
it goes all the way up to the Supreme
Court or not but as long as it is more
politically palatable to pander to the
Hispanic vote and to the media by
pretending that you have a plan that
doesn't end with with closing the border
and at least doing something about the
the the folks who are here illegally
then you don't have a solution what's
amazing to me is both right and left
it's so cynical it really is the right
is in favor of illegal immigration
because they want cheap workers for the
corporation's the left is in favor of
illegal immigration because they want
voters nobody is in favor of illegal
immigration for the individuals here's
my view everybody who's in the country
illegally I'm not gonna say everybody
ought to be deported everybody ought to
be assessed and we ought to determine
whether they are of benefit or of
detriment to the United States and then
on an individual level we should
determine whether they get to stay or
whether they get to go it's bewildering
to me how the IRS can go through a
hundred million tax returns every year
down to what exactly I ate for lunch six
months ago and a kosher restaurant and
whether it was a business lunch or not
but they can't track down 14 million
people and find out whether it would be
good on net for them to be in the
country or not ben shapiro tara called
from charleston west virginia seemed
like a fan of yours
if she wants to listen to you read you
where's the best source for her so you
can read me in a couple of different
places truth revolt org is one of my
websites now you can check me out there
you can also check me out of Breitbart
news where i'm a where i'm a senior
editor at large and then if you want to
listen to me
then KRL a 870 which is the the the
morning answers the name of our show six
to nine every morning pacific time so
9:00 to noon on the east coast
you can listen on karele 870 and then in
the afternoon i do a second radio show
so i do six hours a day my second radio
show is 3:00 to 6:00 in the afternoon
Pacific time on Katie th 770 in Seattle
so you can just Google me and both bills
will come up and you also tweet what's
your hands oh yeah I tweet a lot as you
know I mean I'm rather volatile once
what also a Twitter so it's at Ben
Shapiro if you want to see wild and
crazy stuff political political debates
extraordinaire as well as odd tweets
about Bill Clinton's 1970s kinship to
Chewbacca and then if you ever if you've
ever seen what Bill Clinton looked like
in the 1970s there is a picture of
Hillary Clinton and Bill Clinton
standing next to one another and I
tweeted that out recently with the
caption chewy were home
Eli Wilmington North Carolina
please go ahead Eli actually it's Kelly
different gender Ellie I am saying do
you know what I'm reading off an iPad
and that's exactly what it says I
apologize no problem I don't want to use
my time on correcting that obviously and
the gentleman I don't want to promote
his name actually is quite intelligent
it's unfortunate that he kind of misuses
it I am Jewish and I have to so strongly
object to his trying to portray his own
misguided attempts at politics and
talking fast not all just talk fast and
promoting stereo stereo titles number
one he does a great disservice to the
Jewish people all over the world by
promoting his stereotypes and he's
laughing at it which I find I hold what
he's doing a disdain I just came from a
wonderful Jewish Film Festival here in
Wilmington and thought the film the
Jewish Cardinal and this man and the
Catholic Polish cleric did far more when
they smartened up and had a little more
compassion for people then this guy has
and as far as how he can tell you what
le politically le do you disagree with
ben shapiro when it comes to his
politics as well I'm sorry do you
disagree with ben shapiro when he comes
to his politics as well as some of the
things you've already mentioned i do
disagree with him on politics quite a
lot but it's a separate issue to promote
some stereotypes against the jewish
people and using his jewish terrific
let's get a response that was le in
Wilmington
North Carolina Ben Shapiro I really
didn't realize that the Grim Reaper of
the sense of humor was on the loose
today I mean seriously I mean if the
worst stereotype about juices that we
speak quickly I think we can deal with
that it really that one ranks real low
I'm the list of stereotypes I'm gonna
worry deeply about I'm gonna worry
significantly more about a President of
the United States who's going to promote
a nuclear bomb in Iran and a president
of the United States who has routinely
leaked Israeli national security
information and a democratic party
that's gone along with him and a
Republican Party that basically just
signed off on it in the scent I'm gonna
worry more about that and less about
whether Jews talk quickly how serious is
the so-called rift between the Obama
administration and Israel
extraordinarily serious but this is what
the president wanted all along I mean
back in 2007 according to David Axelrod
he was already talking about how he
wanted to create distance between
himself and Israel because he wanted to
be the honest broker between Israel and
its enemies and the fact is the
president has been radically anti-israel
since he began running for president his
entire staff was staffed by people like
Robert Malley who was negotiating with
Hamas my people like Signia Brzezinski a
foreign policy adviser who is radically
anti-israel under Jimmy Carter my people
Meryl McDonald mcpeak who had said that
in New York New York City was filled
with Jews who basically ran foreign
policy in the United States and the
president has written his spent his
entire life associating with anti-israel
anti-semites
I mean seriously where she khalidi is an
anti-semite he's a Palestinian he's a
Palestinian Liberation Organization
terrorist advocate and and he was a
close friend of President Obama
President Obama spent time in Jeremiah
Wright's church is a radically
anti-israel anti-semitic Church you
spend your entire life in it I've been
to synagogue I've gone to the same
synagogue since I was 11 years old if at
any point any point the rabbi of the the
shul had gotten up and started speaking
about black people or America the way
the Jeremiah Wright spoke about Jews
white people in the United States of
America I would have been out of there
so fast would have made your head spin
but Barack Obama south and for 20 years
don't tell me he didn't vibe any of that
or believe any of that the president has
a belief system and the president is
acting out his belief system in real
time and that has real ramifications for
real people not just used by the way
you're watching it to happen in Egypt
where he's cutting off military
shipments to what is a secular regime in
the face of Muslim Brotherhood uprising
he's busily going against a Saudi regime
that is really I mean a listen I'm not a
fan of the Saudis by any stretch of the
imagination but they're a hell of a lot
better than the Iranian
at this point the President of the
United States is single-handedly turning
Iran into a regional power and and this
is part of a broader policy and the
president of the United States that's
both anti-american and anti-israel and
springs from the same anti Western ISM
that he represents personally Shaun San
Francisco good afternoon Ben Shapiro is
our guest hello Ben pleasure to talk
with you I just wanted to get a your
take on something as a fiscally
responsible lesser government kind of
guy it makes my blood boil somewhat is
the propensity of the us to take
billions of dollars of our taxpayer
money and put it towards the National
Endowment for democracy and other such
NGOs that take a u.s. foreign policy and
it seems as if what they're doing is
something we would not accept here is
interfering with in the internal
politics of countries and you can see it
manifested especially in the Ukraine
where Victoria Nuland bragged that we
had spent five billion dollars over a
period of time to achieve that regime
change and and you can see it followed
through with the constant propaganda
against the people in the east of
Ukraine who were more or less against
the Maidan movement from the beginning
and who were culturally Russian and it
was not them who attacked the Western
Ukrainians it was on hey Jon where did
your interest in these issues that
you've just discussed come from well
it's it's just a history I'm a bit of a
history buff going back to World War two
and you know to understand the Ukraine
it's a very complex country and this
situation is very complex but I think
the facts have not come out in the
United States media about what's really
going on you know and let's hear from
Ben Shapiro so I'm not familiar with the
exact Democratic project that he's
talking about the 501 C 3 that
apparently he's talking about as far as
American policy toward Ukraine has been
egregious I mean the fact is that the
United States basically led on the
Ukrainian revolution under the
assumption that we were going to defend
them when the Russians came and then we
did
defend them on the Russians came so
there's it's no big shock that that was
happening I mean the President of the
United States has so far sold out
basically every potential or real ally
that the United States has in favor of
people that he would prefer to woo and
he sold out Ukraine and Poland
Czechoslovakia all of these countries
and in favor of a Russia that he
basically just signed off on sending
s-300 missiles to Iran I mean the other
day he did that the President of the
United States is actively opposed to a
more powerful United States and its
allies in the world and somebody's going
to fill that gap and people who tend to
fill that gap are the worst people on
the planet
Helen Palo Alto California I think you
might be the last voice today conflict I
would use my time well I find it so
egregious that he would come and
conflate so many slogans and all this
information like Jeremiah Wright that
the Republicans always call up and
something from Obama's past but anyway
my big issue is how the Republican Party
and if you were where that both the
Congress and the Senate all the
Republicans there are all Christians and
the Republican Party and the Congress
excuse me are the gatekeepers of purse
they hold the purse strings and we have
no clue about the budget and did you
know that about twenty two billion
dollars go to faith-based funding and we
don't even know who or what is going
there and most of them are Christians
and how the money for the faith-based
funding and it's almost impossible to
get that information without suing for
the Freedom of Information Act to get
that information and a lot of that money
is funneled and the Congress has put it
more it's alright you know what Helen
we're gonna leave it there Ben Shapiro
final comment I mean as far as
faith-based organizations and the
government's involvement in them I think
it's significantly more dangerous for
religious organizations to be involved
with the government than not the strings
are always attached as far as the
federal government trying to promote
policy through faith-based organizations
I would recommend that people actually
look at where that money is going
because a lot of the time it's actually
going toward adoption projects and and
house building for the homeless and
sort of stuff now I actually object to
that on the grounds that I don't think
the government should be involved in
that but but that that has nothing to do
with is the money actually being spent
on some sort of covert religious attempt
to convert everyone to Christianity as a
Jew I'm not specifically very worried
about that in the United States ben
shapiro best-selling author radio talk
show host editor large at Breitbart the
People vs Barack Obama the criminal case
against the Obama administration
his most recent book just coming out in
paperback thanks for being on book TV
from the LA Times Book Festival thanks
so much for having me and book TV will
continue in just a moment